i don't care what surgeries they have i
don't care what they inject into their
bloodstream they don't belong in women's
sports
i was historically liberal i'm a walk
away democrat i am a lifelong registered
democrat who ultimately feels
politically homeless
it really started maybe right before
biden but
ultimately with the whole biden election
i began to feel more and more
disenfranchised from democrats i would
say i'm politically homeless now because
i don't think the democrats care about
women and girls the democrats are not
even acknowledging women as a sex class
now now men can have babies men need
abortion it's no longer even a women's
issue
what's your gender
when biden came out in the first days of
his presidency with his executive order
which replaced the category of sex at
the federal level with the category of
gender identity
i
it was just it was a slap in the face
and and from that moment i i really
haven't known how to categorize myself
politically i always voted as a liberal
so i from 18 to like 39 38 i registered
republican in 2020 after two politicians
actually told me they did not want my
vote because of my stance on the rights
for women and girls that term feminism
has become so muddied and so
mismatched much like the term democrat
has become so muddied and mishmashed
it's practically lost all meaning they
wanted to put men in prisons and
men on sports teams and my daughter's
school and so yeah that's why i decided
i cannot be a part of this party anymore
that doesn't even recognize my sex class
our lifelong physical developmental
process
can't be reduced to a fixed identity
i
do work that supports women and girls
right to
sex based provisions like single sex
spaces single sex sports
single sex prisons single sex
rape crisis shelters that's why i had to
switch parties even though i don't
necessarily agree with a lot republicans
do as well i have a radical feminist
analysis in my background but i don't
like to identify myself as anything kids
are being taught that they have to trust
that the strange man tells them
before they're allowed to trust their
somebody else i know a lot of
historically liberal people especially
parents who have
felt like they needed to walk away from
the democratic party and i i don't know
who they're going to be voting for in
the new next elections same i think that
we're going to have a lot of people
walking away
[Music]
you